[Music]
i've never been in this spot and
i'm not going to act like i know
what the hell i'm going to do tomorrow
when they when they get in here so
um we're gonna we're gonna
we're gonna do we're always they're
gonna represent the packers the right
way i know that so other than that we'll
focus on what's in front of us
that was mike mccarthy the coach of the
green bay packers after the
to 17 loss to the arizona cardinals at
home after going four out of five on the
road losing all four of the road games
they come back to their sanctuary
against a bad team
that isn't accustomed to playing
december football out in the elements
and the packers lose the game and mike
mccarthy loses his job and we were
watching that game chris aaron rodgers
looked disinterested the whole game i
think he looked even less interested
with his beard and mustache gone right
he was misfiring passes in that last
drive they somehow got in position yeah
the game tying field goal every out
route that he threw was off the mark it
seemed like yeah and to the point where
we were wondering is he injured yeah and
and it just had to happen we talked
about it on football night in america
last week we could see it coming it's
been building and the packers decide
instead of just treading water for the
next four weeks let's go ahead and make
the move and give mike mccarthy a head
start on his next job give us a head
start on finding our next coach yeah i
mean really yesterday was uh to steal
our favorite word from our producer matt
casey i mean a microcosm of the argument
of what's in going what's your favorite
word it's my favorite word now but a
microcosm of everything we've been
talking about with the green bay packers
for the last three or four years it all
came to the top yesterday against the
arizona cardinals like you said who were
a two and nine football team entering
the game and really all the talk we've
had about the struggling offense and not
being able to get roger's help or make
anything easy on him
there was nothing there to be had yeah
he certainly wasn't on his total a plus
game i get that but offense is just too
hard in green bay right now it's it's
hard as far as the talent's not that
great and then two like i've always
complained the schematical uh issues
they have when they're offense they're
very elementary on that side and i think
the green bay brass and people had
finally seen enough and
you know i guess the only thing i'm a
little torn between like it is good they
get on with it and then they can start
getting onto their coaching search
but i do like echo the sentiments of a
guy like tony dungy last night who goes
this guy won a super bowl for you he's
been to the place whoa whoa wait a
minute you've been openly calling for
the guy to get fired i'm not you're
feeling guilty now no i'm not feeling
guilty i'm just saying i get the
argument of people being shocked by him
being fired right now during the season
i get it i think i would have made this
move too if i was the gm of the green
bay packers and i'm but i understand the
other side of it going you know it just
doesn't look good business wise but i do
think it was time to move on they can
start re reaching out the back channels
to agents and things like that and start
to get a feel for
uh offensive coaches or coaches in
general that want to be the head coach
there in green bay it's got to be an
offensive coach i mean i think so that's
why i said that right you've got to get
somebody who is going to work with aaron
rodgers for the remainder of his career
they've already made the financial
commitment to aaron rodgers they're not
going to get a new quarterback no so
it's got to be somebody who is
hand-picked with one job get the most
out of aaron rodgers and you know who i
think that ideal candidate is i don't
i thought we talked about that i don't
think we did i'd like to hear this i
think it's bruce ariens you think it's
bruce harris because yeah bruce aaron's
comes back for four or five years sure
right and bruce you need somebody who
can get through to aaron rodgers who
knows how to push his buttons right
who'll show up with a bottle of scotch
and say let's let's drain this thing
baby and let's start figuring out the
playbook yeah yeah i got you and but i i
just feel like there's a certain
because i guarantee you in the coming
weeks there will be reports from unnamed
sources
close to the situation sure sharing
details about
how difficult aaron rodgers is to coach
yeah right it's unless mike mccarthy is
capable of completely and totally
holding his tongue not venting to any of
his friends in the business any of his
agents anybody he knows because what he
says to somebody is potentially going to
end up being repeated to someone else
but you know aaron rodgers doesn't pay
attention in meetings aaron rodgers has
this bemused look on his face when we're
trying to get through to him what he
needs to do aaron rodgers resist
coaching i'm not saying that any of that
is true i'm just saying i'm going to be
watching for that yeah because mccarthy
needs to push back against the
perception that it's all his fault right
and we saw a little of it last week yeah
a couple of items couple of takes last
week pushing back against rogers and i
think that this next month gives
mccarthy the leader for different
sundays to be doing where rogers is
focused on playing football games
mccarthy gets a chance to rehab himself
as he tries to become a candidate for
maybe that cleveland browns job
something you had been saying for months
that that's where he's going to end up
next i thought there was a chance that's
not i'm not sitting here trying to say
i'm the oracle of the future or anything
like that but you know connecting the
jaw the dots and it's better than being
the oracle of the past yeah it is it's a
lot easier
it kind of
but either way uh i i don't want to sit
here and
blame michael mccarthy for every issue
in the history of the green bay packers
or the last few years hey i'll be the
first one to say it's not like the team
has had been just overflowing with
talent on either side of the ball i mean
this last year's the first year we saw
them really do anything aggressive in
the first round uh a little bit
aggressive in free agency it sounds like
that's going to change so the talent
level wasn't great but i think
ultimately what gets mike mccarthy fired
is games like this where we all know how
talented aaron rodgers is and there was
just too many games over the last four
or five years where it just looks too
hard oh his completion percentage is
down yeah i get that but did we watch
the sunday night football game last week
against minnesota he was under duress
the whole game had to throw the ball
away like 10 times so the course's
completion percentage is down when
you're under duress like what do we make
of the fact that
that aaron rodgers has such a
ridiculously high rate of throwaways
yeah is that an indictment of the
offense is that oh it's another crap
play i'm just going to throw the ball
away i think so i mean when we're
talking about a guy who is the most pro
one of the most precise passers we've
ever seen takes care of the ball as good
as anybody we've ever seen can escape
trouble as much as anybody we've seen
and yet he has to throw those balls away
i think tells you that was why i was
saying a little bit like two weeks ago
it's going to be a different year i
don't think he can carry the squad
because their pass protection is not
there like it was in years past at least
in years past they let him sit back
there and he could buy time and make
magic and get in that zone you always
talk about that he gets into he seems to
do that more frequently when he does
have to move though you see him make
throws on the run sure that's how he
slides into that zone no doubt and he
has not been able to do that as much
this year those close-ups that you see
they're so telling because you can tell
when he's not women you we can read body
language we can see when someone's not
interested i can tell you're barely
interested today are you kidding me no
i'm just kidding you're very interested
but but you know we would we would see
once he starts stringing together throws
and building momentum he gets a more
clear focus and and you can just see it
yesterday it was obvious he was not into
the game and without the beard mustache
you could read his lips a lot more
easily and he was saying some of your
your words your favorite words not
microcosm trust me
uh but uh yeah it just i think it
reached a point where the packers
realized they had to do something even
if rogers didn't lobby for it didn't say
anything to anybody about it the
evidence was obvious something needed to
happen yeah well i i mean yes it had to
happen how many you know we just had too
many years here in recent history of
limping into the playoffs relax oh we
got to go on a run to get in and i like
to remind everybody like yeah relax and
we gotta go and run to get in the nfc
north has not been anything great the
last 10 years so let's just remember
that too it's not like they're they've
been beating down super bowl champions
in the nfc north the nfc north hasn't
had a team go to the super bowl other
than the green bay packers and aaron
rodgers really so uh you know i just
think all those issues kind of came to a
head and again the thing i always fight
about and you know i'm an aaron rodgers
apologist and i love him and i try to
keep as unbiased as i possibly can when
i evaluate quarterbacks i'm just telling
you that we see a lot of his struggles
and i think he is sitting back there and
he finally got to his wits end and he
goes man i'm just sick of watching some
of these other quarterbacks throw to
people wide open 25 yards down the
middle of the field a few times a game
and every throw i got to make is into
the tightest closest window we've ever
seen and i got to hit the bullseye every
time and it's just become too much not
with the lack of scheme not great talent
this year and it all kind of came to a
head so what scheme would you design for
aaron rodgers well i mean any scheme
he's capable of doing any scheme right i
mean what's the best grade quarterbacks
are i mean
hey i would love you know my mind
ultimately right away goes to josh
mcdaniels new england patriots that type
of scheme where yeah they do a little
bit of everything but they have a great
little quick short passing game too
where he can dart it out of his hand at
time and then they have everything else
you need in an offense to of course keep
you honest but that is always the the
scheme i think about right off the bat
to go oh that'd be really interesting to
see him and execute that and all the
nuances that brady has mastered over the
last 18 19 years so mcdaniels gets the
job and calls you to be the
quarterback's coach
between him and aaron rodgers because
you'll know how to talk to aaron rodgers
and get the most out of it i will you
can be the rich cannon i i might take
less if that's the case i might just go
okay let's go i'm out of here the hell
of for you let's go rogers but but that
really is going to be the challenge and
you know i i i put a question on twitter
earlier in the hour
which job is more attractive between the
packers and the good question a year ago
a year ago
we would have scoffed and laughed right
but now with baker mayfield in cleveland
and aaron rod you know bear make baker
mayfield on the front end of his career
right aaron rodgers on the back end of
his career
i don't know which one i'd rather have i
think it's really close when you add
into the fact of guys you know like uh
miles garrett and denzel ward and some
of the young talent that cleveland does
have kind of coming up the ranks that's
exciting nick chubb callaway at receiver
i mean you go through the list and you
start to go man cleveland's got some
young studs that certainly could be
something in the next few years kareem
hunt next year we'll talk about that
well and you look at green bay and you
go what i mean green bay is
again i think we're at this point
because rogers has salvaged the roster
and the team so many years in a row you
go what do we really hang our hat on i
mean an offensive line that's kind of
patchy a defensive line that we see is
not really dominant especially when mike
daniels is in there got some young
secondary guys that's a good thing
receiver wise okay stevonte adams and
who else i mean randall cobb's been
banged up a lot over the last few years
so there's certainly more work to do as
far as building the roster in green bay
right yeah it is odd though and maybe
it's a product of the longevity mike
mccarthy served in that role longer than
anyone uh other than curly lambo i think
i mean it's ridiculous
of his 13th year but you know when brett
favre after he goes to back-to-back
super bowls in 96 and 97 and then isn't
back for the rest of his tenure with the
team there wasn't that same they're
wasting brett favre they're wasting
brett favre and maybe they were just
thrilled to finally have a team that
could get back to the super bowl and win
it they bring the trophy back home and
everything after that is gravy but
there's been a greater sense of
impatience
over the last several years than there
was in the latter years of brett favre's
time with the packers i don't know the
answer to the question i'm just pointing
out it seems like mccarthy's had more
heat on him
for not getting rogers back to a super
bowl than the prior coaches had on them
for not getting brett favre yeah i would
agree with you there i think also too i
mean you know i give mike mccarthy
credit because
i think a little bit of that
conversation is the way he started out
the career and molded aaron rodgers i
mean he kind of got brett favre brett
favre went through that little series
early in the 2000s where he just was
total gunslinger i mean throw it into
triple coverage throw it in the
quadruple coverage i don't care but it's
awesome on highlights and it might be a
touchdown one play but it might be four
picks the next week he got a little into
that aaron rodgers as we've seen here
mccarthy kind of got that out of brett
favre at the very end before he went to
minnesota and i think what's happened is
we've seen aaron rodgers be one of the
most accurate pastors in the history of
the sport the greatest touchdown to
interception ratio we've ever seen he
does a lot of things the right way and
we've watched enough games now to go oh
wait he's playing really good and
they've only thrown for 200 yards or 180
yards and he's doing a lot and doing the
most he can to get that 180 yards and i
think when the football world
continually watches that on film and and
you watch it on tv you just go yeah
there's something wrong there there's
something missing within that offense
and i think at a more fundamental level
and i hate to say this and all due
respect to brett favre if aaron rodgers
is better than brett favre he is and i
think that's why there's been more blame
on those around aaron rodgers how can
you not get back to a super bowl when
you have aaron rodgers a guy who is
capable of making some of the greatest
single throws we've ever seen not in a
super bowl right and we've been robbed
of the chance to see what this guy can
do in history but we went back and
looked at superbowl 45 some of the
throws he made they're insane all right
incredible insane all right we got to
take a break we'll return it was an
insane crazy day at metlife stadium it
was a trap game for the bears and they
stepped right into it we'll break down
bears giants right after this on pft
live
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports